>
RT2
WIOM
CO
RN
N
I WILL TELL YOU WE MADE -- THE
PRESIDENT MADE A CLEAR DECISION
NOT SENDING A DIPLOMATIC
DELEGATION NOT FOR SECURITY
PURPOSES BUT HUMAN RIGHTS AND
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TREATMENT OF UYGHURS.
HOWEVER, WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
E U.S. OLYMPIC COMMITTEE.
ATHLETES ARE GOING.
THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO CHEERING AND ME AS
WELL FROM HOME.
>> Bill: WE HOPE EY STAY SAFE
ALONG THE WAY.
>> Bill: ABSOLUTELY.
>> Bill: THE WORLD WILL BE
WATCHING THIS COUNTRY.
NO ANSWERS ON COVID.
THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY SAID HE
BROUGHT THIS UP WITH PRESIDENT
XI.
HOW FIRMLY?
>> THE PRESIDENT NEVER HOLDS
BACK AND ALSO RM IN HIS
CONVERSATIONS I CAN PROMISE YOU
THAT INCLUDING WITH PRESIDENT
XI.
HE HAS HAD A LOT OF DIRECT
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM.
>> Dana: LAST QUESTION FOR YOU.
I HAVE A LOT OF EMPATHY ON THE
PRESS THINGS.
I FEEL LIKE I CAN BE IN THE
ROOM AND THINK WHAT YOU ARE
THINKING.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAID LOOKS
AT HIS WATCH AND SAYS I GUESS
I'LL GO ANOTHER 24 MINUTES I'M
CURIOUS WHAT YOUR EXACT HEART
RATE WAS AT THAT POINT?
>> I'M A PRETTY CHILL PERSON IN
GENERAL.
I MAY NOT ALWAYS SEEM THAT WAY
IN THE BRIEFING ROOM BUT I WILL
SAY I KNEW -- I WATCHED AND
KNEW HE WAS HAVING A GOOD TIME.
HE ACTUALLY LIKES ENGAGING WITH
REPORTERS AS YOU ALL KNOW HE
WAS ON THE HILL FOR 36 YEARS AS
A MEMBER OF THE SENATE AND IN
CONGRESS MBERS WANDER AROUND
AND REPORTERS ASK THEM QUESTION
AND THAT'S WHAT HE IS USED TO.
I KNEW HE WAS HAVING A GOOD
TIME.
>> Dana: I WAS HAVING A HEART
ATTACK FOR YOU.
>> Bill: THE BUILD-UP FOR THE
PRESS CONFERENCE WENT FOR FIVE
DAYS AND HOW SOON YOU ANNOUNCED
IT.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE HIM TO JOIN
US AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE HIM
TO JOIN THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
CORPS MORE OFTEN THAN JUST
YESTERDAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> HE HAS ANSWERED QUESTIONS
250 TIMES IN THE LAST YEAR IN
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS.
I WILL PASS ON YOUR INVITATION
BECAUSE I WILL SEE HIM SHORTLY.
>> Bill: THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
PLEASE COME BACK AND WE'LL DO
IT MORE OFTEN.
>> Dana: GOOD LUCK TO THE
BENGALS, EVERYONE.
THANKS, JEN.
>> Bill: